an erosion alone is not the
cause of all our divinity
there are other forces at work and
one especially much more powerful
they come to the chopping come
for the picking come by the phone
more migrants depend on top
than on any other problem
but more powerful than all these middens
is the machine it can pick more couples
in 20 minutes in a human hand can pick in two
days it doesn't clean enough yet it is being
perfected but who can tell one day it may
be picking every ball of cotton in the world
Anita Leonora that's how fast it goes the
newbies family are just five dollars an hour
with anything your life
multiply this monster by 10,000 and take it
to some new space in the world with such an
army it would clear the ground for a
great new country in no time at all